قال رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني ان هناك
تقدما في المفاوضات للتوصل لصفقه بين
اسرائيل وحماس وشدد على انها الفرصه
الوحيده المتاحه لتهدئه الوضع وخلال
تصريحات ادلى بها في واشنطن اكد ان دور
قطر هو الوساطه للتوصل لحل تفاوضي يعيد
الرهائن ويوقف القصف والقتل
اعتقد في الوقت الحالي ان بامكان القول ان
التقدم الذي حققناه في الاسبوعين الماضيين
يجعلنا في موقع افضل مما كنا عليه قبل
اسابيع راينا ان العمليه برمتها كانت تعمل
بشكل جيد في نوفمبر ما ادى الى الافراج عن
109 رهاء للاسف انهارت هذهه العمليه في
ذلك الوقت وزادت الحرب حده ما ادى الى جعل
الوضع اكثر تعقيدا كما اوضحت كان هناك طلب
واضح بتحقيق وقف دائم لاطلاق النار قبل
المفاوضات ولذلك انتقلنا حسب ما اعتقد من
وضع الى اخر يمكن ان يؤدي الى وقف اطلاق
النار بشكل دائم في المستقبل وهذا ما
نتمناه جميعا لاننا نرى معاناه سكان غزه
وحجم الدمار هناك الان دورنا الاساسي
كوسطاء هو بدل ما بوسعنا للتوصل الى حل
متفاوض عليه يعيد الاسرى سالمين الى
بيوتهم ويؤدي ايضا الى وقف قصف غزه وقتل
المدنيين نحن نرى الارقام ترتفع بشكل
ماساوي ونرى ان ما يحدث في غزه لا يؤدي
الى اعاده الرهائن